as schools nationwide struggle to
finalize reopening plans some have
abruptly
changed course because of coronavirus
outbreaks
meg oliver is in elizabeth new jersey
home to one of the state's largest
school districts
this week it voted to hold all classes
remotely that meg that's not what the
governor wanted to hear is it
that's exactly right anthony it was an
act of defiance after new jersey
governor phil murphy for
months insisted on some form of
in-person learning
but in a major reversal the governor's
office tells us he will announce a plan
later today to facilitate remote
learning as an option
it reveals just how uncertain this
coming school year will be
it became fruitless to continue to try
to do what was impossible
so they're going to spend the next five
weeks making remote learning the best it
possibly can be
pat politano is a spokesperson for new
jersey's elizabeth school district
whose board monday moved to take classes
entirely
online he told us more than 400 teachers
have already opted out of in-person
classes over health concerns
among them first grade teacher marie
titchner tichner told us she applied for
a medical exemption because her husband
is immunocompromised
but she's also stressed about how
distancing guidelines would hurt her
ability
to teach if she were in the classroom as
schools nationwide figure out how
best to reopen some have already
encountered speed bumps
schools in elkhart county indiana are
now authorized to start in person
reversing course after first announcing
they'd begin the year
digitally that decision had prompted
families to protest in favor of
reopening last week
and days after this photo surfaced of a
jam-packed hallway at north paulding
high school in georgia
at least nine coronavirus cases were
confirmed there
prompting a temporary switch to remote
learning
the reception to that choice was not
without controversy
is the china virus prevalent in children
at a paulding county school district
meeting tuesday some cast doubt that the
coronavirus would affect their kids
those studies indicate children can be
infected
one teacher was not amused i had
students
making fun of the fact that i choose to
wear a mask
that's unacceptable back in elizabeth
new jersey politano says the priority is
giving students a quality experience
at home but their children are entitled
to equitable education and we're going
to work like hell to see that they get
them
in addition to their educational needs
more than 75 percent of students in
elizabeth public schools
qualify for free or reduced lunches the
district will continue their grab-and-go
plan to serve those meals to students
and every student will receive a device
and anthony just one more note that
first grade teacher we talked to she
told us
it's not just about the health concerns
but in terms of the social distancing
guidelines
she doesn't know how she could comfort a
first grader if they started to cry
on the first day of school that's a
challenge meg it really is thank you
very much